foreign
Walkers people are saying very hateful
comments telling us to hike to Mecca
associating us with immigrants and
refugees making uh you know connotations
about backpacks
packs and bombs Etc people just making
really awful horrible comments
[Music]
we kept it a secret from our
participants and it was brilliant like
you could see the look in their eyes and
how overwhelmed they were
at seeing prayer signs in the
countryside like it does make them feel
homely
we have received quite a bit of
Christmas criticism people are
questioning why we're putting you know
science to Mecca in a Countryside people
are suggested we're spoiling the
countryside
we just don't have the outdoors embedded
within our cultural and lifestyle norms
and that very much accounts for the lack
of confidence the lack of awareness
sometimes the lack of self-belief for
venturing out into these spaces that's
what we're trying to tackle very much
head on
but there's people within our
communities that already feel less
empowered to get outside lacking
confidence than if there is
the existence of racism and in some
islamophobia
then this can very much hinder
or prevent people that feel less
empowered to get outside comfortably and
confidently some of the shocking and
disgusting abuse we have received online
since yesterday people have an issue
with Muslims whether we were Muslims and
running or Muslims in cycling which is
Muslims getting out together having fun
they'll always have an issue
islamophobia can't be denied it exists
in community it's in politics it exists
in the media it exists everywhere and it
needs to be called out
[Music]